we have a tragic update to a story we've
been following about a six-year-old girl
who disappeared in South Carolina Faye
maurice wetland vanished Monday after
school her family says she was last seen
playing in her front yard police
announced yesterday they found her body
in her own neighborhood and the body of
a man was found nearby Janet shamlian is
in KC South Carolina Janet horrible
story tragic situation what do we know
so far
Jericka good morning to you as the
memorial grows here at the entrance to
Fey's neighborhood detectives are now
calling her death a homicide however
they are not saying who was responsible
describing it as an active investigation
they did however say there is no danger
to the public is with extremely heavy
hearts that we were announcing that we
have found a body
that the coroner has identified this
face marine swept Department of Public
Safety Chief Byron stell group could
barely hold back tears when he broke the
news Fay Marie sweat lik was gone the
six-year-old was last seen in her front
yard Monday afternoon after getting off
her school bus a massive effort to find
her followed more than 300 officers
including the FBI searching the town for
Faye this time no arrests have been made
you need to know that this is a fluid
investigation and that we were working
diligently our police did not say
whether the man found dead during the
investigation is related to Fay or her
death the first-grader lived with her
mom and grandmother investigators say
all relatives including her father were
cooperating Vice President Mike Pence
was in Charleston and noted her tragic
death I would just urge everyone in
South Carolina hug your kids today and
keep this little girl and her family and
her community in your prayers how will
this community deal with this tragedy I
think everybody has to process the grief
on their own pastor Micah merchant has
three children in the same school were
Faye was in first grade now you'll have
to tell them tragic news how will you
explain that tragic news is never easy
nothing prepares you for gonna cry with
them just gonna be honest just gonna cry
with them
faith school Springdale Elementary
issued a statement calling her death
heartbreaking and asking any school
families with information to contact
authorities there was so much hope here
Anthony me so much hope that things
would turn out differently
heartbreaking indeed Janet thank you our
condolences to face family